foreign
thank you for coming and thanks for the
invitation
so
uh so I'll be talking about worrying and
Border working in this talk and it will
be very very basic I promise that so if
you understand basic algebra you should
be able to follow me throughout so two
spoilers
and one is there is almost no connection
to perform website sorry about that and
second spoiler which is
more important that 20 of my slides are
already covered by annamaya markups and
trainer so thanks to that but I will
probably repeat just to remind you some
basic stuff but I will go through them
quickly so that
we are on the same page
so uh
yeah so this is a joint work with full
view who is in Christian who is in
Warwick Gora who is an FBI and Vladimir
who is
Copenhagen okay
okay so the basic idea as follows I'll
I'll sort of very quickly go through the
library complexity
and then I'll Define worrying and Border
worrying and talk about some of the
results that we will get and then I'll
conclude and there is a very thin layer
of connection and then probably on one
slide that I'll be talking about algebra
natural proof to connect something about
worrying Rank and whatever that's it
Okay so
yeah as uh print also started that we
want to basically tackle P naught equal
to NP and
so the point is this proof does not work
and because n is not n is not one I mean
this kind of stupid
proof does not work but the point is
that instead of this intellectual proof
barriers there are actual proof barriers
that why natural proofs whatever you can
come naturally why this does not work
right and that is basically the famous
result by rajbala brutish where they
showed that sort of I mean they came up
with what we can call Natural proofs and
they say that all the all or most of the
lower boundary results are visible
natural and they basically don't work to
prove be not about anything
and to tackle that
uh so very few techniques are actually
known that would potentially break and
one of them
was introduced basically by this paper
in this paper by murmur and Sony where
they published in 2001 which is called
the GCT one
where they say that okay
um uh so this algebraic P naught equal
NP which uh which is VP not equal to vnp
there you can actually talk about uh so
you can set up questions uh in more
algebraically or more geometrically and
you can try to attack that question
and that potentially break the natural
probe barrier by symmetric equation I
will not get into exactly what I mean by
symmetric attention but I can actually
tell you
answer
one quick thing so let's say I have uh
I have a matrix X and I take a transpose
and also sorry I I take X
and take A and B such that determinant
of a times B is 1 so X is a matrix
so
so all the you can say that all the
polynomials if
says that
if so let's say Sigma 1 this is the
sigma 1 where this is the sigma 2 map
all the maps such that basically a b
sort of invariant is the only
determinant one and up to some constant
so these are sort of symmetries of this
is basically the group you can Define
the group and you can say that okay this
is these are the symmetries of
determinant and similarly you can do
something
not that
exactly the same but close to that for
permanent as well now why this
calculation is important because for
most of the polynomials this does not
hold
so in other words I can put this and say
that determinant and permanent as Prana
was saying
I'll also Define explicitly determined
permanent but determined versus
permanent this question so determinant
and permanent these are two polynomials
they have nice symmetries where most of
the polynomials don't have nice
symmetries so maybe there is a way to
actually separate determine versus
permanent which is not natural because
that sort of breaks the natural root
barrier
so that's why they actually concentrated
on this gcp and how do you find the
symmetric and so on and that's why they
said okay we study sort of the more
geometric problems like determinant
permanent and we try to find some
representation theoretic uh properties
of these two polynomials which is more
geometric but I guess you understand
what I'm trying to say these are two
polynomials where we want to separate
them by understanding some properties
which most of the polynomials don't have
so probably this already breaks the
natural proof battery
now in this paper
and so honey Define more geometrically
but you can also independently so Peter
producer in 2001 almost in the same year
defines sort of the similar thing more
algebraically and we'll see sort of the
algebraic definitions in this talk
but they are sort of the same so you can
also talk about algebraic definitions of
this I'll I'll so the point of the point
is I will talk about border complexity
in in the algebraic setting just via the
lens of worrying Rank and body worrying
that I'll Define
in the coming slides but that's that's
what I'm going to do
as I said I'll talk about the algebraic
Nation a notion and uh yeah so as I said
dcg basically tries to uh prove lower
bounds using these symmetries which
basically you can use uh representation
Theory as a big geometry and all kind of
mathematics and probably you can prove
that because that is not natural as I
already argued
and what DCT water complexity does is
basically it tries to capture and notion
of approximation and we also see what
kind of approximation we are talking
about because in approximation you can
talk about different different kind of
documents
okay
so as I said the under the point is to
understand what a compressive the point
is to understand approximation of
certain polymers
okay so here is a quick definition of
determinant we all know what is uh what
is the determinant so it's a so symbolic
determined is basically you take n cross
n Matrix each entries each entry is a
new variable x i j and determinant n is
basically a n Square variable polynomial
which is the three the obvious High
School uh definition you basically
expand through rows and columns you get
a N squared idiot in degree polynomial
which is determinant
and the permanent polynomial is almost
the same but without the signs remember
indetermine there's a plus minus plus
minus in the permanent there is no minus
all things are plus these are two
polynomials and these are basically the
two polynomials that one Stripes one
place to understand
and uh
uh print already talk about vvp not
equal to vlp so this question can be
formalized as follows I have a
determinant of M M cross M I want
actually replace each entries by linear
polynomials in the variables and I want
to see whether I can write permanent as
that
and the claim is
I can but then aim has to be super
important there is no way I can do it in
a polynomial polynomial size okay
so this is equivalent to basically the
vnp not in bbp question
so let's see what are the kind of bounds
we know
this is sort of the bound uh we know uh
we know that aim has to be like n Square
which is and uh Bruno Grande actually
proved into very recently very recently
nine years back that aim is upper
bounded by something like 2 to the N
minus one so that's basically the really
easy
okay so this is the valence conjecture
we would like to understand
now just to be in the context again uh
talked about this that in some sense
algebraic classes separations are is
easier in Boolean than Boolean because
we know that if P slash poly is not
equal to NP slash poly then we know that
vvp not equal to VMP and this is an
unconventional laser there is no Gres
involved but if you want to prove it to
our complex numbers of rational numbers
then you have to assume grh
so assuming grh we know that P stars for
nautical Dimensions body
history implies will be not able to
maintain the valence one picture so the
idea is to sort of understand that okay
maybe we should first try to prove this
before
I am aiming for peace transformative
potentials
okay
and in fact of course we saw sort of uh
believe that these these are not same
because if they are then pH Cola says so
so that is where the sort of Boolean
versus algebraic connection stands
now let's try to understand
uh in one slide quickly the natural
proof and then I'll go to the worrying
rank versus
so as I said to you want to understand
we want to prove a lower bound wooden up
lower Bound for models that keeps on
models
and one thing is to actually come up
with a living natural proofs
uh
Al martus
talked about this on my I know I also
talked about this is it so these are the
three properties that we want to come up
with so for anywhere at D degree
polynomials number of monomials is n
plus the juice D so we want to come up
with a polynomial P which is sort of
easy easily conceptable such that if f
is in some circuit Class C N and I want
to prove then the coefficient should
manage there
and
if P should be easily constructible that
is also the complexity of P should be
easy in some sense whatever the
complexity is and if you want to show
something else so for example a random
polynomial should be hard
right in that not that class that sort
of implies that
if you uh if you evaluate at
coefficients of g at P it should be
normative okay so that is how you sort
of set up the lower bound setting in the
algebraic natural Network and the idea
is probably to come up with energy with
natural proof and say that okay the
proofs basically has to be this and most
of the algebraic proofs lower bound
proofs we know are actually algebra
natural proof to fill that
but now in this talk uh
we will try to understand this question
in terms of summer powers model which we
called worrying Rank and its
approximation
so
I'll Define this just in the next slide
so we'll try to understand this setting
the same setting for the worry Rank and
the Border worrying
so till now I think I hope it's clear to
everyone
so
okay so what is worrying right
so worrying language as follows uh
if you have a h which is a homogeneous
degree D polynomial I want to write H as
sum of powers of linear forms what is a
linear form linear form is basically
two definitions homogeneous means each
degree each monomial has degree d
okay so I can take x square y plus X Y
Square because each has negative 3 but I
can't take x square y plus X Y because
this is non homogeneous because x square
y has degree 3 X Y has degree 2 so that
is not allowed let's talk about only
homogeneous
and what is a linear form it is of
degree exactly one so there is no
constants allowed okay and I want to
write H as sum of powers of linear forms
now the minimum r
that I can write H as sum of powers of
linear forms is called the wording rank
it's sort of a measure on a polynomial
okay
the first question is is it defined for
overall homogeneous polynomials right
that's the first question you could ask
because
and
you can show that for any homogeneous
polynomial age this is worrying rank
is finite that means any polynomial
homogeneous polynomial H can be written
as sum of powers of linear forms why is
the case
this is probably easy to check if I have
representation of F and representation
of G I can trivially have a
representation of a plus because I have
f as sum of powers of linear forms G
also has some of the mirror forms then a
plus d trig value has a sum of power
supplying atoms so a plus so if f and g
has finite worrying rank then f plus G
also has a finite networking so all we
need to do is that every monomial has a
finite ring
and what you can show
is that there are trivial uh somewhat
trivial upper bounds but this is sort of
a tight so you can show that for any
monomial
X1 to the E dot X into the e n the the
worrying angle sort of this where e one
is basically the minimum so so let's say
e one less than equal to E2 less than
equal to e n so you basically drop the
minimum one and other things you can
show this is exactly equal to same this
is what we know in particular if you
look at e one equal to E2 equal to e n
that means just look at the monomial x
one of X and the varying rank of this is
2 to the N minus 1.
yes
okay so this will also for every
monomial we know we can do that and
using this we know that every for every
polynomial we can do that to worry and I
guess one thing good
so now let's try to look at one example
which again
let's look at that so let's say I want
to look at worrying rank H equal to one
bivariate degree two polynomials so by
very degree point of two point m s look
like a x square x square plus b x y plus
Cy square right and suppose it's a
square it's a single Square because
wording rank one means it's a single
Square now let's try to understand what
is this so let's say then then that
means that this is of the form Alpha X
Plus beta y square and if you expand
this you'll note that the middle thing
Square minus 4 times this times this is
zero You observe that
foreign
look at Y and Y Square then this will be
like y it does not matter so so this is
also a perfect square if B Square minus
four S is zero
so this is saying
that warning rank equal to 1 is
explicitly the set defined by this
equation b square minus four S is zero
that also a number I talked about okay
how does this tell
you can prove that wiring an X Y of X Y
is greater than one because X Y is what
0 1 0 and 0 1 0 is not in the set x 1
because 0 square a 1 square minus 4
times 0 times 0 is 0 so it's a way of
proving that X Y does not have one okay
so you can Define these two these things
but now as I promised let's talk about
approximations that I promise that we'll
talk about approximations and
and why you will talk about
approximation is also on in
geometrically
also make sense because we are talking
about uh equations where b a b c vanish
so this is sort of a close this is sort
of a variety so it makes sense to talk
about the closed closures but we'll talk
about some some different kind of
closures or approximations here so let's
try to Define that so as I said that
what kind of approximation do are we
talking about because you can come up
with probably many sort of definitions
for example
uh physicists can say that oh this is r
and this is R but whatever I don't care
cosmologists can say that okay Pi is one
I don't care even theoretical computer
scientists of say 10 to the 5 is just a
constant it is inside order I don't care
so it depends on what kind of
approximation you are really talking
about right so the point is here we we
will try to understand what kind of
approximation we are talking about in
terms of worrying rank
okay so let's look at
these example
x square y I want to write x square y as
sum of three cubes because x square is
degree three I want to write x square y
s degree 3 Cube so I can write it as
this by the way uh our field is
basically complex assume that everything
is always complex so it is a sum of
three cubes right because you can
basically include this cube root of six
or cube root of minus X or whatever
inside and these are all fine so these
are sum of three cubes and you can also
show that this is exactly three that
means you cannot write x square y as sum
of two cubes it's a very trivial
exercise you can just say that of x
square y if it is of the form something
Q Plus something q that will be a
trivial con contradiction so x square y
cannot be written as sum of two cubes
okay
now look at this example
consider a
Epsilon which is
non-zero
and look at this expression one by three
Epsilon times X Plus Epsilon y Cube
minus X Cube
you basically expand that and you take
basically Epsilon closer and closer to
zero take the limit but never zero don't
put if and equal to zero but like sort
of take the limit
so if you get the polynomial x square y
so what is happening is that
whenever you take a very very small
Epsilon let's say epsilon is point zero
zero zero zero one
then what you can do is you can
sort of insert this cube root of three
Epsilon inside X Plus Epsilon y right
because again this is a small constant
so you can always use this so if H
Epsilon in other words is a sum of two
cubes whenever Epsilon is small any
non-zero constant right but the moment
Epsilon tends to zero or if you put
Epsilon equal to so you cannot put here
Epsilon equal to 0 but in this
expression it makes sense to put Epsilon
equal to zero but nonetheless the limit
which is like X bar y
suddenly you have proved that this is
three
so there is a mismatch going on right
so I will repeat again so what is
happening is that you have x square y
you can sort of approximate that by sum
of two cubes
but suddenly at the limit you cannot
so in terms of the
whole picture this is sort of the
picture so let's think about this set as
worrying rank less than equal to one
this set as warring angle is n equal to
2 this set less than equal to 3 4
so what does this polynomials say x
square one
note that x square y cannot sit inside
this set
and it cannot sit outside this hair as
well because if x square Y is here then
there should be a sequence that actually
comes here in between so that will make
make say that H Epsilon has Warrior N3
that cannot happen so it has to each
each if each Epsilon has to stay inside
this but H cannot release
come here so it has to be really in the
Border somehow otherwise there is no
point that it it appears
so just to be clear out I have H Epsilon
approximating x square y this H Epsilon
has to be here H cannot be here because
otherwise you have to have to
approximate something by H Epsilon here
which is contouring this point H Epsilon
less than equal to two so x square y has
to sit really in a border so think of
this like in the border and that's how
we Define the Border
exactly can be defined as this
so what a border working rank of a
polynomial H is basically I I want to
write sum of powers of linear forms but
Li has Epsilon terms like Epsilon
Epsilon square and so on it has also 1
by Epsilon and so on so over equipment
this field and I want to take the limit
and I want to write it as sum of course
so the same definition but with the
limit right so by the definition or by
the example that I showed you last in
this last slide what border worrying
neck of x square Y is 2 that's what we
sort of showed
because you can rewrite the same example
like this uh you can sort of insert this
three Epsilon to the one by three inside
and this is basically the sum of 2 Cube
as a limit okay
so Epsilon to the one by three
yeah so okay but what you can also do is
Epsilon to the one by three you can
rename it at let's say epsilon Prime
that also tends to zero and then
Solutions
yeah it doesn't matter
so
so x square y can be written as sum of
two cubes so our border where you can
this is two
now as I as I said now the Y the I will
not talk about that but the lower bounds
or more most of the lower bounds for
worrying and because the trivial lower
Bound for lowering rank is basically by
a partial derivative
equations and so on they basically that
is basically natural proof
and that will also give lower Bound for
Border worrying because as I already
mentioned this is basically border
basically captures all the all the
things that will also finish at the
limit right so whatever you can whatever
natural proofs will come up with
worrying
will also hold for Border body neck
right
so that means we really don't understand
worrying Rank and Border worrying in
this lens if you really want to
understand Warrior Rank and Border
Origins from this lens of a natural
troops or defining equations we don't
really understand the uh difference
between worrying angle whatever you name
here is a question
if border worry rank of a polynomial is
K what can you talk about the worrying
rank of this polynomial it's a natural
question that how large can the Gap be
what is known is a d to the K kind of
upper bound so that means if K is like
constant this is still poly d
and what is also known is that if water
running rank is less than equal to five
then this is like order D it was
is K
can you show that worrying rank is less
than equal to 4 to the K times d
okay
so that means for any constant k
what are you rank is sort of
order d
so this basically generalizes this and
of course this is a huge Improvement of
the triviality to the K because when K
is constant let's say 100 then this
gives only D to the 100 or something
but this gives still order D although
the order is really large but
and
sorry uh so the proof has something
where K is less than b yeah I don't know
what happens when K is 0 than D but that
is most probably not a very interesting
case any we always and I mean so okay
I mean it can for hard polynomials we
know that K is really large we know that
but yeah our proof has some
technicalities where you can't show it
for K greater than T but L is equal to D
we can do that
man
so even if Point T is log D then wording
rank is spoil B that's what uh the
question uh the result is
and but still this equation we don't
really understand the equations for
General K but still we we are able to
show some kind of uh this bound
yeah and uh okay so this is one result
of between worrying and Border wording
Rank and then I'll uh conclude by this
slide so
there is another interesting connection
which was sort of uh observed by Kumar
in 2020 he said that if border worrying
rank of polynomial if it's k then I can
always approximate if
as this product minus one I mean forget
about the constant it's like a constant
multiple
so if you look at Epsilon limit Epsilon
take limit Epsilon then basically this
is true
but for most of the yeah so that implies
actually for any if this kind of thing
is possible because we know that border
boring rank or worrying like is sort of
universal for any homonymous this is
finite so for any polynomial if we know
that we can write this as
sort of this
Alpha times 2.1 plus Li minus 1 as a
limit it's a very trivial model so you
can always write if as that and in
particular when border Vari neck is
small this Ace is also small this proof
is this being showing that the obvious
question is what's the converse if I
write can write if as a limit of this
can I also show that whatever is too
small that would sort of prove that this
is really really like a interesting
model but closely connected right
but that is not really the case because
trivial you can write X this monomial in
this form you write x 1 to the N times
product minus 1 and you can compute and
you can say that x 1 up to X N is also
in the model as a limit
note x one up to X N has border wording
rank known to be 2 to the N by root n or
something like that so we know the
exponential lower Bound for Border
variant for monomial
so trivially we cannot expect a Converse
of this
right so again just to be clear what I
am saying I know that if border warning
is small I can write this as a product
minus one
up to some multiple as a limit
and I want to sort of show a Converse
that how powerful is this model is I
know even monomials can be computed in
this model which has border wording like
large
so the question is what else can compute
as I said border body neck is
exponential n we actually in the same
paper we show that these are sort of the
only case that is possible in the sense
that if f is indeed a limit of this
model then either we are in this case
border worrying rank or we are actually
in this case but even instead of x 1 up
to X and we have L one of the Ln linear
polynomials note that you can always
write L one up here and also in this
form because x i instead of x i it will
be aligned so this is Trivial in this
form so these are the only two sort of
possibilities in this model so
previously uh last year or two years
back uh with nitin and pratik we showed
that a much more General result but we
only showed that these are sort of a
small ABP but this is much more strong
result for this specific model
and we also generalize this instead of l
i we can sort of look at let's say two
cross two or three cross three matrices
think of one as identity Li instead of
Li you have matrices two cross two
matrices or three cosine matrices of
linear
uh polynomial silicon sort of look at
this model or the limits and you can
study and it it turns out that this kind
of model is already
say
proofs of uh with three MVPs like for
example with three MVPs we know are sort
of conflict in the sense that VF is bbb3
we know that any V3 AVP is as powerful
as formulas so this kind of uh proofs
also can be interpreted in this model
that will show we are not going to go
into that but all I'm trying to say is
even this model
is very very powerful if we'll talk
about limits it's a very simple product
minus one but that could give a lot of
reasons okay so I'll conclude
the first question is obviously can we
show that if border warning rankings is
second okay then worrying rank is also
polynomially bounded what we showed is D
times 4 to the K bound
right
can you show up on the polynomial upper
bound
and the second point is can we find
explicitly the equations I mean we sort
of know that there exists equations and
so on but can we explicitly find the
equations or we can say that okay here
is a equation for Border exactly K but
somehow we X we sort of manipulate them
and try to uh give a gap between
worrying and bordering can we sort of
exploit that and show something like
that that we don't know
and uh we sort of also have some bit of
results in this step five models so
let's say I I have Sigma weight Sigma
with Sigma that basically means that sum
of powers or sum of g i to the D but
each worrying and angle also is less
than or equal to S small something and
when you basically uh
to be constant we can talk about some
border so we can talk about some the
strengths of or weaknesses of this model
so what is the class when we allow
approximation in which this model and so
on so Manta is actually here in the
audience so you have some results when
that open is constant so uh so basically
this is like a composition of so sum of
polynomials so composition of Origins
you can think of that so yeah
so yeah so that's all I wanted to say
thank you
so
can you say something about so if you
know that your polynomials
you know there is an expression
involving deception can you say
something about the degree
so yeah we can't uh I mean we I mean
that was the point that we can say about
something about that I mean locally we
can that I mean to prove the weight the
proof goes we can sort of locally say
that the Epsilon T is just one but when
you look at the whole Pro so the proof
okay so the point is that you can think
of L one to the D plus n to the D plus
eight three sounds let's say N1 and N2
has the same constant
[Music]
foreign
like once the constant terms are same we
can sort of group them and prove limits
and for that we can prove Epsilon power
like a k minus one okay or something
like that but when it's globally we
cannot at least we could not from this
proof okay
but uh yeah if you can prove Epsilon
will be like that then it it's a trivial
you can Interpol it and prove that okay
I mean that's worrying is
yeah okay
[Applause]